[Applause]
let's close out with something wildly
came across on social media this is what
I'm
[Applause]
liking artists use so many things to
create their Works paint charcoals clay
even reclaimed objects um but have you
ever seen this because I've never seen
this that's Michael and he patiently
uses the sun and a magnifying glass to
burn images into a wooden canvas that's
insane to me check out some of his
finished
pieces
what
what that's so insane to me we have
Michael on the line right now watching
on Idaho News 6 what's up man you are so
gifted hey Kelly how's it going I mean
first of all you have like the patience
of Job I'm like that has to take some
time how did you come up with this I've
been an artist for many years I went to
college for Fine Arts but it wasn't
until 2012 that I um packed my bag and I
went on a long journey from South Korea
to Greece and I knew that I wanted
wanted to travel and create Arts so I
needed to find a tool that I could fit
in my pack without taking up too much
weight and one day I think it was the
day that I started to realize I was
losing my hair I felt the Sun so beating
down on my my forehead that I knew I
could use the Sun as a source of
inspiration or as the tool to paint so U
I never looked back and it was at that
point that I picked up a magnifying
glass and I started to create artwork uh
some of them take anywhere from 1 to 40
hours often times standing in direct
sunlight um right now it's 12 degrees
out in Boise Idaho but it's sunny so I
could technically walk outside and
create art but it's freezing I could
also do it in the summertime too when
it's 120 out and um as long as the Sun's
shining I can uh create incredible
pieces of art like the ones you see
behind me and I also get an incredible
workout from it it's it's something that
um mixes the beauty of exercise and
creativity it's amazing what's like your
teaching method you teach people now to
do this right I teach people but I want
to preface everything I'm about to say
uh do not try this at home I'm a skilled
professional I've been doing this for
years um I been teaching this technique
uh since about 2013 and um I used to go
to uh parks and and the beach on on my
free time and I would set up I'd set up
a piece of artwork and I'd start working
and um behind me I would have a crowd of
30 to 40 people Gathering asking me how
I um how I did this so I said here and
I'd pull out a magnifying glass a pair
of protective eyewear and a hat which I
provided for everybody and I taught them
how they too can create art with the sun
and so um you know despite the patience
I think the the most fundamental part of
the whole thing is it it teaches uh and
inspires children the magic behind it
the magic behind the power of the sun
which um it's it's truth and it's real
and it's it's guidance and it's patience
and it's respect and um for children to
to see The Gleam in their eye that
they're what they're witnessing is Magic
and for me to tell them hey this is
truth it's not a rabbit and a hat trick
this is this is the power of the Sun in
your hand that is so magical you just
made it way cooler just with that
explanation you should write a
children's book I was like what thank
you so much Michael this is so inspiring
like what you do it's so different
creatively speaking and what dedication
it takes is incredible I'm liking your
post right now right thank you so much
Kelly for having me on your show
absolutely thank you for creating such
beautiful art I mean that's not all a
man our season long partner pilot pin
makers of precise the go-to pin of the
Kelly Clarkson show want to honor truly
Unstoppable artists just like yourself
sir so they're going to be riding you a
check for $1,000 how's that sound no way
awesome thank you thank you so much
Michael have such a great 2024 thank you
to all our guest this hour Sophia verata
Teresa Caputo and seishi have a great
day y it's not
[Music]
[Applause]
CH thank you guys y have a great night
I'm going
home